notre commission d'enquête entend
aujourd'hui Monsieur Marc bottenga
botanga botanga député européen depuis
la crise sanitaire de la covid-19 la
politique conduite par l'Union
européenne en matière de santé a connu
une petite révolution des actions
inédites ont été entreprises comme
l'achat en commun de vaccins et
d'équipements sanitaires
des acteurs européens se sont vus
octroyer de nouvelles missions comme
l'Agence européenne du médicament l'Emma
désormais chargés de la surveillance et
de la prévention des pénuries de
médicaments de nouvelles structures ont
été créées comme les rats Hera chargé de
la gestion des crises sanitaires
mais la crise sanitaire a aussi soulevée
de nombreux interrogations voire des
craintes quant à l'action de l'Union
européenne faut-il promouvoir davantage
de coordination entre États membres en
matière de santé voir aller jusqu'à
renforcer la réglementation européenne
pour encadrer davantage les politiques
nationales par exemple en matière de
stock ou de prix faut-il renforcer la
transparence des décisions prises au
niveau européen par exemple concernant
les achats groupés de médicaments et de
vaccins monsieur Marc bottenga vous vous
êtes beaucoup mobilisés au sein du
Parlement européen sur ces sujets
d'approvisionnement ont produit de santé
alors que l'action d'Union Européenne
pour lutter contre les pénuries qui sont
le cœur de notre sujet ici au Sénat dans
le cas de cette commission d'enquête
sera appelée à se renforcer au cours des
prochaines années il nous est apparu
intéressant de recueillir votre point de
vue sur les priorités et les obstacles
de l'action communautaire
en particulier nous étions à Bruxelles à
Bruxelles lors de lorsque la Commission
a annoncé un nouveau report de la
présentation du nouveau paquet
pharmaceutique européen très attendu qui
a finalement été dévoilé la semaine
passée nous souhaiterions obtenir votre
votre analyse sur les propositions
formulées sont-elles pertinentes
suffisantes anticipez vous des
négociations serrées notamment avec les
industriels donnent-elles un rôle
suffisant au pouvoir public pour pouvoir
réellement limiter la fréquence et
l'impact des pénuries médicaments
pour cette audition d'une durée
d'environ une heure et demie nous vous
laissons tout d'abord la parole pour un
propos général d'une dizaine de minutes
puis madame Laurence Cohen le rapporteur
de notre commission d'enquête vous
posera des questions plus précises je
vous indique que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et qu'elle fera l'objet d'un
compte-rendu publié monsieur bottenga
vous avez la parole
j'espère que vous m'entendiez bien oui
le son
parce que le son passe bien ou pas
vous m'entendez comme il le faut ou pas
vous m'entendez mal
vous m'entendez pas du tout
vous m'entendez ou pas du tout
oui on vous entend on vous entendez
dans ces cas-là tout d'abord merci pour
l'invitation c'est un honneur de pouvoir
contribuer à vos travaux
je vais tracer bref dans mes propos
d'introduction vous avez raison la
Commission européenne a finalement
proposé les grandes lignes de sa réforme
de la stratégie pharmaceutique
européenne et je pense que il y a dans
cette proposition
des choses très positives il faut
souligner
et je pense qu'il y a des points sur
lesquels on pourrait être plus plus
critique
je vais commencer par un point qui me
semble fondamental dans le travail
autour de la pénurie
c'est la question de la transparence
donc nous avons vu pendant la période
covid un problème de transparence
notamment par rapport aux chaînes de
production et d'approvisionnement
cela nous a mis dans une position
souvent difficile pourquoi parce que
nous ne savions pas
ce qui était produit ou quand ce qui
était vendu à qui quand
et donc non plus ou pouvait y avoir de
véritables pénuries de véritables retard
dans la livraison par exemple et où il
s'agissait tout simplement d'un choix
disons d'une entreprise particulière de
livrer à un autre pays
en fonction par exemple du prix que ce
pays était disposé à payer
je pense donc que
une des premières étapes à franchir
c'est de vraiment imposer une
transparence sur non seulement les
capacités de production de capacité
productives mais aussi sur ce qui est
produit effectivement
au sein de l'Union européenne et à
travers les chaînes de production et
d'approvisionnement
ça permettrait par exemple d'éviter
certains spectacles qu'on a eu ou
certaines chefs d'entreprise ont même
refusé de venir on a explications
nécessaires par rapport à des retards de
livraison lors de la période vaccin
covid ça ça me semble une première chose
et la stratégie de la Commission
européenne va dans ce sens là et je
pense que c'est quelque chose de positif
qu'il faudra appuyer
un deuxième élément très présent dans la
stratégie la Commission européenne est
celle de l'imposition d'une mise sur le
marché au niveau européen ça veut dire
pas seulement dans un seul pays mais une
généralisation donc une mise sur le
marché généralisé dans différents pays à
partir dans les deux ans en fait de
l'arrivée sur le marché de ce produit de
ce produit pharmaceutique ça me semble
être important parce que ça va obliger
les entreprises d'une certaine mesure
évidemment nous parlons ici aux
conditionnel parce que toutes ces
mesures sont des propositions de la
Commission européenne vous le savez
comme vous l'avez indiqué qu'il aura des
négociations avec les États et avec le
Parlement européen sur la concrétisation
de ces mesures on verra à la fin quelles
sont les mesures européennes
véritablement prises
mais donc la deuxième chose ça me semble
important d'effectivement pouvoir mettre
des conditions en fonction de la mise
sur le marché et d'avoir suffisamment de
produits pour fournir le marché européen
dans son entièreté je vous rappelez
pendant la période covid un vrai défi
était le risque que certains pays
auraient accès au vaccin
au sein même de l'Union européenne et
d'autres n'y aurait pas ou peu accès
c'était d'ailleurs un risque qui s'est
concrétisé au début quand certains pays
ont formé une alliance pour des achats
conjoints
à des pays avec une certaine capacité
financière que d'autres pays n'avaient
pas et donc le fait de européeniser si
on veut
cette dimension là non seulement au
niveau de l'achat mais aussi au niveau
de la mise sur Mars sur le marché me
semble un élément positif
là où parce que je veux quand même
avancer de trois éléments critiques
aussi là où la proposition de la
Commission européenne me semble limiter
c'est par rapport à ce que vous appelez
la relocation ou le la production sur le
continent européen
je pense que la Commission n'a pas osé
aller
très clairement
dans un sens qui lui est pourtant
suggéré par différents rapports du
Parlement européen
d'abord dans le sens de prendre vraiment
les leviers le volant si on veut la
politique de recherche et développement
sur le continent européen c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous savez en fonctionne
beaucoup avec des partenariats publics
privés un des défis de ses partenariats
c'est que souvent
il y a un décalage entre les priorités
des entreprises qui elles favorisent ont
tendance à favoriser les médicaments à
hauteur rentabilité tandis que pour les
priorités des États notamment en matière
de santé publique d'autres médicaments
devraient recevoir et de la Recherche
Développement dans d'autres domaines
devaient recevoir la priorité c'est un
problème très concret que nous avons eu
avec le partenariat public privé
Imi imi2 ce qui est l'initiative pour
les médicaments innovants
et qui a été épinglé par le Parlement
européen
là je crains que la proposition de la
Commission ne va pas vraiment changer la
donne je regrette un deuxième problème
je pense une deuxième question c'est la
capacité de production sur le territoire
européen donc si certaines garanties
sont proposées sont
demandés des entreprises je pense que on
fait l'impasse sur l'ambition l'ambition
qui devrait être à mon avis le
développement de une infrastructure
publique
du médicament pour garantir pour un
nombre de médicaments et ça peut être
les médicaments stratégiques ça peut
être les mamans pour lesquels
l'industrie privée ne garantit pas la
production
on peut on peut discuter ensuite la
liste des médicaments ça peut être la
liste des médicaments essentiels de
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé mais
des garantir pour ces médicaments là une
capacité productive sur le continent
européen et la seule façon ou la seule
garantie réelle ce serait alors d'avoir
une capacité publique c'est quelque
chose qui a été demandé publique ou par
pas pour profit c'est quelque chose qui
a été demandé par le Parlement européen
dans un rapport sur la pénurie des
médicaments en 2021
c'est quelque chose qui a été répété
dans dans deux rapports du commander
deux études commandées par le service
d'études du Parlement européen
et malheureusement
Commission européenne ne franchit pas le
pas on peut discuter tout à l'heure de
Hera que vous avez mentionné et pourquoi
actuellement
ne répond pas à ce besoin donc erreur
nous avions avec le Parlement européen
demandé à era très ambitieux sur le
modèle de la barda américaine
éventuellement
nous avons reçu quelque chose qui est
actuellement
à sous-directorat général de la
Commission européenne
ce qui est extrêmement peu ambitieux et
ce qui ne répond pas en fait aux besoins
que nous avons identifié pendant la
pandémie
on parlait de pandémie mais en réalité
on a aujourd'hui des pénuries de
médicaments vous ne savez bien en France
pour des produits qui parfois sont des
produits tout à fait j'ai pas envie de
dire banal mais presque qui sont des
produits pas du tout pas du tout pour
des maladies rares pas du tout des
produits innovants et donc là je crains
que les propositions pour avoir deux
critiques de points positifs et de
critiques des propositions de la
Commission je pense que les deux points
fondamentaux à la fin malheureusement
mauvais soir et ça vaut aussi justement
pour les principes actifs parce que je
sais que votre commission aime parler
justement de cet aspect là qui est
important de voir la qu'est-ce qu'on
peut vraiment reporter à l'Union
européenne par rapport à cette principe
actif et à quel niveau est-ce que nous
dépendrons toujours d'un commerce parce
qu'on va évidemment pas pouvoir vivre en
autarcie
par rapport à l'équilibre entre ce qui
doit être fait au niveau européen et ce
qui doit être fait au niveau des États
membres on peut en discuter
je pense qu'on aurait intérêt à fédérer
une série de politiques qui aujourd'hui
malheureusement à partir de l'Union
européenne
isolé et arrive avec des des petits
projets
isolés travaillant en silo plutôt que
d'avoir une coopération et plus de
recherches collaboratives basées sur un
modèle de sciences ouvertes je pense
qu'on aurait intérêt à fédérer ça au
niveau européen où chaque État ensuite y
apporte quelque chose nous avons des
projets européens dans ce sens là qui
ont été des succès que ça soit l'Agence
spatiale européenne que ça soit le CERN
c'est pas ça dépasse le cadre d'Union
Européenne mais il y a des exemples
concrets et chaque pays pourrait alors
en fonction de cette points forts et de
ses qualités et apporter quelque chose
voilà je pense que je suis arrivé à dix
minutes donc je veux respecter
rigoureusement le temps des questions
mais pour avoir un panorama un jeu un
peu général de
des grandes lignes de la politique
pharmaceutique proposée par la
Commission européenne avec deux notes
critiques je pense que je vais en rester
là pour l'instant
très bien merci beaucoup j'ai tout de
suite passé la parole à Laurence Cohen
rapporteur
merci Monsieur botanga pour votre propos
liminaire donc vous avez effectivement
abordé le paquet pharmaceutique européen
c'est vrai que il y a eu beaucoup de
retard et qu'on se demandait s'il allait
sortir avant les élections européennes
donc ça c'est plutôt un élément positif
vous avez souligné donc deux points
positifs à renforcer et puis des mesures
qui sont plus contrastées et donc plus
négative parmi me semble-t-il les
mesures qui pour qui peuvent poser
problème au niveau européen
en tout cas par les différents États
membres est-ce que vous ne pensez pas
que c'est la réduction de la protection
des données de huit ans à 6 ans et donc
selon vous
est-il nécessaire de limiter
ces barrières concurrentielles pour
stimuler l'innovation et du coup la
question qui en découle pour moi c'est
également la question des brevets et
notamment de la durée des brevets
pharmaceutiques parce que ils ont été
pendant la pandémie contestée comme
étant un frein pour que chaque pays
puisse bénéficier notamment des vaccins
donc j'aimerais vous entendre sur cette
sur cette question sur cette question là
la deuxième question que j'aimerais
j'aimerais vous poser c'est la question
concernant le manque de transparence
vous l'avez vous l'avez abordé en disant
que c'était un facteur extrêmement
important tant au niveau de la chaîne de
production et d'approvisionnement mais
quelle mesure en fait vous vous pensez
nécessaire de de préconiser notamment
d'ailleurs puisque vous aviez déploré
pendant la
pandémie le manque de transparence des
processus d'achat groupés au niveau
européen et poussant donc la Commission
européenne a publié les contrats d'achat
de vaccin donc est-ce que vous pouvez
sur cette question précise nous dire
nous donner plus d'éléments ma troisième
question c'est le facteur prix des
médicaments alors c'est vrai qu'il y a
des tarifs de remboursement qui sont
différents suivant les les systèmes qui
ne sont pas les mêmes d'un pays européen
à un autre et donc c'est une c'est une
prérogative qui reste largement à la
main des des États membres nous avons vu
lors de nos auditions ici en France le
fait que il était
reproché à la France notamment par
rapport aux
médicaments d'imatures leur prix trop
bas et nous avons pu encore constater
dans une audition dans plusieurs
auditions que ce soit hier ou
aujourd'hui que nous en tout cas au
niveau de la France au moment de
l'examen du budget de la Sécurité
sociale
l'enveloppe destinée à la part de
médicaments est assez insuffisante c'est
la variable d'ajustement pour faire en
quelque sorte des économies et on a vu
un espèce de des espèces de vases
communicants si vous voulez ou on tire
le bas les médicaments matures pour
faire face au prix
exorbitant des des médicaments innovants
donc par rapport à ces questions de des
prix de la variation des prix
finalement comment est-ce qu'on peut
tâcher tendre
à une harmonisation des prix au niveau
européen qui éviterait la compétition
qui peut s'exercer entre les différents
pays européens on l'a vu là encore
pendant la covid ou finalement il y a
une espèce de surenchère pour pouvoir
disposer des médicaments ou des vaccins
l'autre question que j'aimerais vous
vous posez c'est ça concerne les mains
nous avons pu effectivement avec la
Présidente nous rendre sur place et
avoir donc l'audition de de l'Emma
est-ce que selon vous
cette
structure cette oui c'est agent de ces
structures
à une des compétences qui sont
satisfaisantes en termes de prévention
et de surveillance de
l'approvisionnement en médicament nous
en fait nous avons eu l'impression lors
de notre déplacement que les ambitions
étaient présentes la volonté était aussi
présente mais que finalement les moyens
alloués aussi bien en termes humains
qu'en terme financier n'était pas
obligatoirement au rendez-vous des
ambitions donc vous en tant que député
européen est-ce que vous avez cette
cette même cette même analyse
mon autre question concerne les pieds
européens on a pas mal posé aussi cette
question et j'avoue qu'on a été un petit
peu des un pointé ou déçu par les
réponses parce qu'il y avait pas un
engouement particulier par rapport à ces
dispositifs et donc enfin qu'elles en
sont les raisons est-ce qu'ils sont
parce qu'ils ne sont pas suffisamment
valorisées est-ce que les informations
de circulent pas suffisamment enfin
comment finalement ils peuvent être
vraiment un outil parce que ça pourrait
être un outil intéressant au plan au
plan européen
enfin c'est sur les le sujet des aides
publiques
est-ce que vous
estimez que les aides publiques qui sont
destinées à la production et à
l'innovation pharmaceutique manque
aujourd'hui d'efficacité au regard des
objectifs d'intérêt général vous avez
vous êtes exprimé d'ailleurs durant
durant la toujours la pandémie et au
sujet des vaccins en expliquant à juste
titre que si je vous cite on va payer
trois fois pour le même vaccin on est en
train de se prosterner devant les
entreprises pharmaceutiques vous aviez
eu donc un jugement assez dur est-ce que
vous pouvez aller donc plus loin dans
ces cette analyse des aides des aides
publiques et ma toute dernière question
c'est
qu'est-ce que vous pensez du fait de
d'essayer de ce qu'on de se concentrer
au niveau européen sur une liste courte
des produits critiques c'est-à-dire pas
pas les médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeurs mais vraiment une
liste beaucoup plus courte une centaine
150 150 produits et pour lesquels on
pourrait au niveau européen avoir
l'ambition d'avoir une intervention
publique dans la production de de ces
médicaments pour essayer justement de
répondre à ces tensions assez pénuries
puisqu'on a vu les manques qui
existaient aujourd'hui avec les
politiques telles qu'elles sont menées
je vous remercie
pour ces questions je réponds tout de
suite vous avez la parole oui tout à
fait
merci beaucoup désolé à distance c'est
parfois un peu un peu compliqué à
comprendre mais je vous remercie en tout
cas pour pour les questions et pour pour
la parole je vais essayer de les prendre
dans l'ordre donc par rapport à
l'évolution par rapport à la question
des droits de propriété intellectuelles
dans la proposition de la Commission
européenne en fait c'est un peu plus
nuancé que cela je sais que l'industrie
a relevé effectivement ce que vous avez
dit
donc ce qui se passerait c'est que la
protection
disons de réglementaire serait au total
de huit ans qui inclurait 6 ans de
protection des données et deux ans deux
années de exclusivité de marché donc de
protection de marché donc c'est avec en
plus si jamais l'entreprise respecte
cette mise sur le marché partout en
Europe comme je décrivais tout à l'heure
on pourrait arriver au total à une
protection jusqu'à allant jusqu'à 12 ans
donc c'est un mécanisme où il y a un
j'aime pas utiliser le mot
affaiblissement mais il y a une
flexibilisation disons du régime de
protection mais qui peut quand même
rester très très large
en fonction de non seulement la mise sur
le marché donc ça ça vous garantirait
deux ans de plus en plus il y aurait six
mois de plus prévu si vous répondez à un
besoin médical non satisfait et encore
six mois de plus si jamais vous arrivez
à faire des essais cliniques comparatifs
donc ça au total ça vous fait arriver à
quand même une protection très longue
avant de arriver pourquoi est-ce que
[Musique]
comment dire ce bonus est donné par
exemple les deux ans pour la mise sur le
marché
si jamais vous mettez le produit sur le
marché partout en Union Européenne dans
les deux ans c'est évidemment pour
encourager les gens les entreprises à
garantir un accès aux médicaments
partout en Europe et la Commission
estime elle-même que ça devrait
augmenter l'accès à ce médicament
d'environ
15%, ce qui signifierait 65 70 millions
de personnes or ça c'est ce qui a écrit
dans dans les textes il y a que la
proposition moi même je suis un peu vous
l'avez vous l'avez relevé je suis un peu
plus critique par rapport à ça tout
d'abord au niveau de l'innovation je
pense que nous avons donc le modèle des
droits de virtuels tels que nous le
connaissons actuel est en fait une
innovation relativement récente
dans le secteur de la santé donc il y a
eu l'accord ATP que vous connaissez bien
qui a été réformé mais jusque dans les
années 70 en au niveau européen même en
Italie il n'allait pas du tout de soi de
donner des droits exclusifs à des
entreprises pour des médicaments il y a
eu un certain mois un arrêt très connu
d'un cours constitutionnalisienne dans
les années 70 en disant oui vous pouvez
mais jusque là ça n'avait pas de soi et
qu'est-ce qu'on a quand même observé au
niveau européen globalement c'est que le
retour sera investissement pour des
fonds de recherche attribuées à la
recherche pharmaceutique à
progressivement diminuer et donc ce que
nous voyons ce que nous obtenons
aujourd'hui en matière de nouveaux
médicaments mais véritable ou pas des
petites adaptations mais véritablement
une innovation qu'on consistante par
rapport à ce que nous obtenions pour le
même euro investi dans les années 50
c'est beaucoup moins
donc il y a eu il y a une crise du
modèle d'innovation actuel et là où moi
je ne suis pas seul c'est aussi un
constat qui est partagé pas mal dans
dans la communauté académique et au
niveau d'institutions internationale
je suis critique des droits de cœur
pourquoi parce que on crée des données
des signaux de données
avec des monopoles qui n'incitent pas
forcément même à améliorer beaucoup son
produit parce que une petite
amélioration peut déjà où un petit
changement ne parlons même pas
d'amélioration peut déjà vous garantir
une nouvelle protection
un nouveau monopole finalement sur le
marché et donc je suis assez pour le
fait de investir et de faire le choix en
fait de la science ouverte
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
bizarre parce que beaucoup de nos
institutions académiques sur ce modèle
là donc il y a souvent et c'est un peu
la contradiction où nous sommes beaux de
la recherche par exemple fondamentale
nous sommes beaucoup dans la science
ouverte nous sommes beaucoup
dans ce modèle là et pour de bonnes
raisons parce que ça permet une
recherche collaborative c'est ce que
l'OMS a proposé au moment de la covid
avec ce qu'elle appelait le setap qui
était le coronavirus technology access
pool en anglais en français c'est
traduit souvent comme mécanisme d'accès
aux technologies ou d'accès
technologiques pour le coronavirus en
disant essayons de mettre ensemble ces
comment dire ces chercheurs permettons
l'heure de travailler sur les
technologies ensemble et limitons les
monopoles privés sur sur cette
technologie donc je pense pour
encourager et pour la recherche et
l'innovation il faudrait
plutôt être plus prudent avec l'octroi
de ces de ces trois exclusifs de ces
droits monopolistique le contrat
argument qui est utilisé souvent qu'on
entend souvent c'est à dire oui mais
c'est
encouragements pour les entreprises
d'investir dans la recherche et
développement
moi la première chose que je demanderai
là encore c'est la transparence combien
de l'argent
public ou privé est effectivement
utilisé à des fins de recherche et
développement nous ne savons aujourd'hui
pas il y a peu de transparence sur ce
que les entreprises investissent
eux-mêmes ou elles-mêmes
sur combien de fonds publics sont
effectivement utilisés
et comment elles sont utilisées là il y
a deux choses à imposer une transparence
aux entreprises privées et deux
évidemment si vous fabriquez on y
arrivera tout à l'heure vous même
certains médicaments vous avez le
meilleur vue sur le coût réel entre
recherche et développement et production
il y a là-dedans
un chiffre qui est sorti qui est
intéressant qui qui a fait l'objet d'une
étude présentée au Parlement européen
par rapport à au virus covid-19
vous lisez pour les vaccins les
autorités disons au public ont
globalement investi 31 milliards de
dollars
dans la recherche et développement et
ensuite l'achat de ces vaccins
globalement ça veut dire les autorités
américaines européennes pas au niveau de
l'Union européenne que certains États
membres
et certains institutions internationales
comme le CP c'est un donc on arrive à 31
milliards
la même étude a pris les dépenses
déclarées des entreprises qui sont de
plus ou moins 16 milliards
vous voyez qu'il y avait un problème
s'il est soutient public où les
investissements publics et les achats
arrivent à 31 milliards
et les entreprises ne reconnaissent ou
ne déclarent elles-mêmes que 16
milliards de dépenses on n'est pas en
train de parler dans total des 47
milliards on est en train de parler de
potentiellement de l'argent public à
utiliser à d'autres fins
que vraiment le développement la
recherche se développements et la
production de ces vaccins
et cette étude a en fait elle a fait au
sein du Parlement européen était évoqué
à juste titre dans la commission
d'enquête covid du Parlement européen
parce que elle pose une question
fondamentale au-delà de l'utilisation
des fonds qu'on a qu'on attribue au
développement du vaccin covid c'est à
dire quelle vue est-ce que nous avons
réellement
sur ce qui se fait avec les fonds
publics et sur ce qui se fait au sein de
ces entreprises donc dans ce sens là moi
je suis a pour une plus de flexibilité
afin de favoriser le la source ouverte
pour la recherche et deuxièmement de
imposer une transparence pour que on est
une idée éclaire parce que sinon on
reste dans un oui non nous allons dire
quelque chose de l'entreprise vont dire
le contraire en réalité tant qu'on n'a
pas les données et que elle nous donne
par accès aux données on restera dans un
8 et dans un an pas dans un jeu de oui
ou non il me semble très peu productif
sur le fond le modèle de recherche et
l'innovation nous avons besoin de plus
de sources ouvertes après ça peut se
faire de manière différente ça peut se
faire à travers des
licences non exclusives par exemple donc
il y a différents modèles je vais pas
ici préjugés lesquels monnaie utilisée
mais parce que j'en suis un peu
comprendre que au sein d'une unité de
recherche on ne veuille pas que
l'invention soit tout de suite accaparée
par une entreprise privée donc on peut
travailler avec des licences non
exclusive il y a toute une série de
modèles là-dessus mais ça me semble
important ça pour votre première
question
deuxième question qui évidemment liée
question de la transparence
nous pouvons nous devons
oser et la Commission va dans ce sens-là
mais je pense qu'il faut aller plus loin
c'est que quand on donne
ou quand on octroie des soutiens publics
que nous devons en
revendiquer exiger une transparence
totale il n'y a aucune raison que nous
utilisons aujourd'hui à des fonds
publics sans garantir une transparence
le problème effectivement vous l'avez
relevé
des vaccins des contrats vaccins a été
que au niveau européen on est arrivé
on ne vous entend plus
on vous entend pas
on peut le savoir non
vous nous entendez
oui donc vous on vous entend pas il y a
pas eu un changement dans vos réglages
parce que nous il y a rien qui a bougé
ce qui peut mettre éventuellement des
oreillettes avec un micro
il est plus là
je ne sais plus du coup vous m'avez
perdu mais
on allait passer à l'aimant
je pense que la transparence des
contrats c'est un enjeu de
santé publique je vais vous dire
pourquoi je pense que tous ceux qui ont
peur du vaccin
tous ceux qui ont peur
en général de la politique
pharmaceutique ou
voient leur peur renforcer par un manque
de transparence
le fait par exemple épingler par la Cour
des comptes européennes par la
médiatrice européenne des SMS enfin des
messages WhatsApp entre la président de
la Commission européenne et un président
directeur général de une entreprise
pharmaceutique
inspire pas confiance
aux gens c'est très clair
on a parlé la médiatrice a parlé de
mauvaises administration mauvaise
gouvernance donc je pense que nous
devons oser la poser
c'est faisable mais malheureusement
c'est pas le choix qui est rira à la
fête donc les gens qui actuellement gère
ces négociations de contrat est assez
fermé même le Parlement européen n'a pas
eu un droit de regard garanti donc on a
une présence d'observation mais qui est
vraiment formelle donc on a été exclu en
fait de ce mécanisme ce mécanisme a été
incorporé au sein de la Commission
européenne et en fait négocier
aujourd'hui dans la même opacité
qu'avoir je pense que c'est mauvais
c'est mauvais pour une question principe
je trouve que quand il s'agit de fonds
publics il doit y avoir une transparence
B c'est mauvais d'un point de vue de la
santé publique où la confiance des gens
se construit aussi à travers la
transparence
par rapport à la pénurie de médicaments
le lien avec la
pénurie sur ce sujet
non le lien avec la pénurie ben j'ai
répondu à la question des contrats comme
elle la question était était
dirigée vers ça mais je pense que la
question sur la transparence est
fondamentale par rapport à la pénurie
pour pouvoir prévoir des pénuries
pouvoir prévoir les pénuries et voir où
il y a effectivement
des goulots d'étranglement par exemple
ou pour pouvoir faire ce monitoring à
cette supervision se suivit la
transparence est fondamentale la
transparence sur la négociation des
contrats aussi de vous pouvoir dire
voilà où est-ce qu'on intervient où
est-ce qu'on négocie qu'est-ce
qu'on ouvre les États avaient un droit
de regard un certain amant sur les
négociations de contracte mais il faut
que ça soit généralisé pour qu'on puisse
justement anticiper
et savoir et aussi mais voilà c'est
évidemment complet une transparence que
je disais dans mon propos introductif
une transparence sur la chaîne
d'approvisionnement donc il faut pouvoir
savoir quelle est la capacité productive
réelle quelles sont quelle est
l'exportation qu'est-ce qu'on exporte où
etc donc je trouve que le rapport avec
la pénurie se trouve à ce niveau là je
sais pas si c'est clair sinon vous
vous me rappellerez alors de répondre
vous continuez avec la question sinon je
passerai aux autres questions rapidement
peut-être la question des prix elle est
fondamentale
[Musique]
tout d'abord faisons de tout pour
limiter les prix
quand on finance publiquement nous
pouvons au moment la physique imposer
des conditions d'accessibilité
ça c'est une au moment donc déjà en
amont nous pouvons
demander imposer certains conditions en
matière de accès c'est pas du tout
bizarre c'est quelque chose qui peut se
faire dans le cadre aussi d'un marché
public d'ailleurs donc il y a aucune
raison qu'à ce niveau là déjà on ne
négocie pas le prix
deuxièmement quand il y a des demandes
excessives parce que l'analyse que vous
avez fait évidemment je la partage
entièrement sur le jeu qui est fait
entre médicaments disons comment est-ce
que vous avez appelé innovants d'une
part ou maladie ou médicament mature
évidemment ce jeu là il se fait pour
l'éviter il faut aussi qu'on ose
refuser que des médicaments innovants
qui ont été en partie financées avec des
fonds publics aux qui ont bénéficié de
la recherche publique que ce prix soit
fixé de manière complètement aléatoire
enfin l'entreprise nous avons eu en
Belgique pour parler de mon pays le cas
où on a dû faire un
financement disons populaires
pour sauver la vie d'un enfant parce que
le prix du médicament de l'injection
solgen small à l'époque était fixé à un
prix pro et victoire
évidemment vous savez très bien que pour
la sécurité sociale ce n'est pas
faisable ça serait la façon de plier la
sécurité sociale d'un pays
parce que ensuite vous faites un
chantage entre oui mais ce que vous
voulez que cet enfant meurt ou est-ce
que vous faites payer la sécurité
sociale c'est évidemment un chantage
absolument inacceptable mais que nous
pouvons prévenir aussi en amont
je trouve que ça c'est pas un détail
ensuite il y a certains autres outils
qui peuvent être mises à qui sont à
disposition des étages je ne connais pas
vous mets en excuserez la situation
précise en France mais la licence
obligatoire ce que vous appelez je pense
la licence d'office est un outil qui
peut être utilisé dans certains cas la
Commission européenne vient de proposer
de développer un mécanisme licence de
fils au niveau européen
je pense que c'est important c'est une
piste
mais ça ne doit évidemment à mon avis
pas affaiblir le le pouvoir national des
états il faut que les États ont certains
états pas tous les États mais les États
qui ont choisi d'avoir cet outil dans
leur ordre législatif doivent pouvoir
l'utiliser et je pense être un outil
utile
à la fin quelque part en aval je dirais
évidemment je trouve qu'en amont quand
on développe une soit on achète soit on
développe en recherche et développement
on met des conditions et là il y aura un
arbitrage à faire sur quel médicament
sur l'Agence européenne du médicament je
partage le constat que vous avez fait je
pense qu'il y a de l'ambition les moyens
sont plus problématiques vous savez
aussi que une bonne partie la majorité
des fonds que l'Agence du médicament au
niveau européen reçoit aujourd'hui vient
actuellement de
de ici la lumière s'est éteint
vient de
d'acteurs privés donc ça veut dire le
consultant au nom vous aurez expliqué ça
au niveau de l'Emma c'est que il s'agit
de de service en fait que l'Agence du
médicament
offre à des acteurs qui veulent mettre
sur le marché certains médicaments
et je pense qu'il y a un équilibre à
établir de
oser aussi si on veut cette rôle là de
oser dire voilà nous devons mettre les
fonds publics là-dedans et garantir à ce
niveau-là une transparence
supplémentaire aussi de l'Agence du
Médicament ça ne serait pas de mal
il y a plus de débats là-dessus aux
États-Unis qu'en Europe malheureusement
en ce qui concerne les maps pour
rebondir c'est que les pénuries font la
pénurie de médicaments fait partie du
portefeuille de l'Emma il y a un plan de
charge qui a été en tout cas présenté
par l'Emma et donc
voilà c'était aussi la demande c'est à
tel les moyens les mas de mettre en
oeuvre ce plan de charge puisque dans
les objectifs il y a une cartographie il
y a la liste des médicaments dit
essentiels il y a pas mal de sujets
comme ça qui sont nécessaires en façon
des outils indispensables pour derrière
décliner des actions efficaces
pas de question elle est je peux y
répondre rapidement pour l'instant la
réponse est non
je pense que pour l'instant je veux dire
le le cahier de charge établi et donc
l'élargissement de la compétence
l'agence Emma en soit peut-être une
bonne chose on peut avoir une discussion
est-ce que ça doit relever de l'agence
médicale européenne ou est-ce qu'on aura
besoin d'une autorité différente pour le
faire par exemple une barre européenne
aurait pu jouer un rôle là-dedans mais
dès lors qu'on attribue cette compétence
à l'agence médicale européenne il faut
donner les moyens
parce que sinon on va être sur quelque
chose de faut pas sous-estimer cette
tâche là surtout dans un contexte où de
nombreux acteurs sur le marché
que faire et la transparence
donc on est dans une situation on l'a vu
et je suppose que vous l'avez vu en
France comme on l'a vu dans d'autres
pays européens on s'est rendu compte en
fait des limites d'informations
dont disposer les autorités publiques
et on s'est trouvé pour pour ne pas les
citer avec une entreprise
britannique donc on devait en fait la
Commission européenne à essayer de les
convoquer à Bruxelles pour avoir des
informations sur leur processus de
production on a dû faire le tour pour
faire une cartographie des capacités etc
on a un défaut actuellement
d'information et on veut un monitoring
un suivi par le l'agence médicale
européenne de ces processus il faut lui
donner les moyens et je pense
qu'actuellement les moyens sont
insuffisants ça c'est une réponse un peu
un peu nette étrangée à votre question
mais voilà c'est je pense c'est
l'analyse
qui d'ailleurs à mon avis est faite
là-bas aussi de ce que j'ai entendu
moi-même
sur la question du pied moi
effectivement je pense c'est un outil
qui qui peut avoir son sens
je pense c'est important là-dedans qu'on
met au volant
les besoins donc je sais qu'il y a eu il
y a un an environ un projet de 16 États
européens je ne sais pas si la France en
faisait partie mais je crois bien de
mémoire pour un pic
européen sur la santé
je pense que c'est un moyen qui est
important qu'on peut utiliser mais où il
faut faire attention
[Musique]
à ce que le les la santé publique soit
au volant pour le dire ainsi
trop souvent ces produits ces projets
européens d'intérêt communs sont
comment dire son financés selon
l'intérêt disons d'un projet qui existe
déjà ou en disant voilà on pourrait on a
envie de faire ça déjà depuis longtemps
financièrement cela et du coup on en
arrive avec des projets où il y a un
lobbying sur qu'est-ce qui devient un
projet d'intérêt commun et que on n'est
pas presque dans un marchandage ou un
pays va dire oui mais le mien a vraiment
d'intérêt commun un autre groupe de pays
va dire non on prenait le mien donc je
pense que ça a beaucoup de potentiel je
suis en faveur d'un tel projet
mais soyons clairs que ici bon 16 étages
je trouve que c'est déjà consistant
comme projet mais garantissons que les
priorités soient fixées par notamment
les autorités publiques en fonction des
besoins de santé publique et qu'on ne
tombe pas dans à nouveau une
privatisation si on veut entre
guillemets je parle de privatisation
mais de de
comme on l'a vu dans les Himis la
fixation des priorités à d'autres
acteurs je pense qu'il est vraiment
important c'est un bel outil que les
États peuvent utiliser utilisons-le à
bon escient
par rapport à l'efficacité des aides
publiques non et ça vaut au niveau
national aussi nous voyons des
entreprises qui reçoivent des aides
publiques et qui néanmoins licencie des
chercheurs or nous avons en Europe
aujourd'hui un grand besoin de
chercheurs et de recherche
non seulement en recherche fondamentale
mais aussi recherche appliquée
et le licenciement pour moi
par des entreprises qui reçoivent des
fonds publics dans un secteur
stratégique on parle pas d'un secteur
quelconque je ne ferai pas le même
discours si on parlait d'autres secteurs
mais dans un secteur aussi stratégique
pour non seulement la santé publique
mais toutes l'économie européenne je
trouve qu'on doit pouvoir imposer
une production une recherche sur le
territoire européen et donc aussi un
maintien de l'emploi quand j'ai vu en
pleine pandémie des entreprises qui
recevaient des fonds européens ou ou
d'état membre licencier des chercheurs
ça m'a d'un point de vue de
de développement médical et
développement industriel européen
abasourdi je vais
vais être je trouve que ça il faut
pouvoir être très clair là-dessus
parce que nous avons un savoir-faire en
Belgique en France en Allemagne et un
savoir-faire garantie son le et les
ponts publics sont à moyen de le faire
si on y met les conditionnalités pour ça
c'est la dernière question
la liste courte
écoutez moi je veux être pragmatique je
pense que l'important c'est d'avoir ce
chiffre nous avons dans le passé U et
nous le voyons dans d'autres pays nous
avons eu une production publique au
vendeur de la logique du profit peu
importe c'est pas le modèle qui me qui
m'apporte c'est pas une question de
mais une garantie sur un nombre de
médicaments on a eu des instituts
publics du vaccin jusqu'à récemment
encore aux Pays-Bas au Danemark etc ça
existait dans différents pays
en Espagne on est de nouveau en train de
faire des expériences
dans ce sens là nous pouvons le faire
et que ça soit alors qu'on commence avec
100 médicaments avec toute la liste de
médicaments essentiels de l'OMS j'ai
envie de dire peu importe de manière un
peu provocatrice
l'important c'est qu'on commence
l'important c'est qu'on commence et si
on a une liste de 100 médicaments ou 150
avec lesquels on veut commencer on peut
commencer c'est déjà pas peu
on sait pas peu et donc moi je serai
pour je serai pot par contre je voudrais
juste
faire un avertissement que les risques
de se trouver à produire uniquement des
médicaments que qui sont considérés non
rentables par les entreprises privées
parce que là on risque d'avoir une
situation dans laquelle les entreprises
financées par le public arrivent
[Musique]
comment dire être
pratiquement en perte dès le début
et donc il faudra trouver un mélange
de produits ou d'une part voilà on est
au niveau du financement et au niveau du
revenu il y a vraiment un bénéfice pour
la société et on n'écrit pas juste on
soit pas juste des bouches
pénuries si on veut donc une certaine
entreprise n'a plus envie de produire un
certain produit on va le faire à perte
et donc voilà ça je voudrais un peu
peut-être si vous permettez faire un
avertissement contre ce modèle là donc
dans le mix de médicaments qu'on utilise
faudrait réfléchir à ce ce paramètre ou
cette variable là aussi voilà merci
beaucoup
ok merci beaucoup de tous ces éléments
je vais faire le tour des collègues je
sais pas si certains veulent intervenir
non
moi j'ai une question
j'ai une question un peu trial sur la
dernière la dernière question de la
liste des produits critiques en fait
elle concerne la liste des médicaments
dont on sait qu'ils sont fragilité en
matière de de production en tout cas
pour lesquelles on a une dépendance
extrême parce qu'il y a des monopoles et
puis parce qu'on a vécu aussi le fait
que dans des périodes épidémiques on les
surconsommé donc là pour le coup on
n'avait plus assez de disponibilités
donc c'est ça en fait les médicaments
critiques c'est un peu c'était
médicalement particulier et pour et pas
et par définition qui sont en situation
de mettre en fragilité la santé publique
ou en difficulté à santé publique sur
des périodes circonscrites donc en fait
pourquoi la liste est limitative parce
que ça peut pas être 3000 médicaments
qu'on peut considérer critique comme
étant critique c'est-à-dire qui sont à
la fois essentiels pour la santé à la
fois en fragilité et à la fois
susceptible d'être surconsommé l'idée du
pôle
[Musique]
contrepartie
en contrepartie pouvoir répondre à la
pénurie quand il y a quand il est
nécessaire déclencher un plan de de ce
cours de pénurie
je pense que effectivement c'est un sens
de faire au niveau européen ça n'empêche
pas de faire une niveau national et je
pense qu'il y a une dynamique qu'on peut
partager alors sur le nombre pourquoi
est-ce que je sais d'où vient le chiffre
mais vous savez aussi que la liste des
médicaments essentiels identifiés par
l'OMS a beaucoup plus long
donc
et l'OMS ne vient pas non plus de nulle
part après l'OMS encourage les États
membres justement de faire leur propre
liste d'identifier leur propre liste
[Musique]
est-ce que la question nationale est
européenne là-dessus moi je suis assez
favorable à une action européenne
pourquoi parce que ça permet comme je
disais tout à l'heure des économies
d'échelle ça permet une certaine
puissance aussi
un certain pouvoir par exemple ce qui
est il y a certains États membres pour
qui ça pose moins un problème mais on
parlait d'une licence d'office une
licence d'office pour certains pays
implique que ce pays individuellement
tout seul devrait affronter en
pharmaceutique qui a un chiffre
d'affaires parfois supérieur à son PIB
donc c'est extrêmement compliqué dans ce
sens là l'action européenne peut
vraiment permettre de dire voilà nous
nous imposons en tant qu'acteur en plus
les forces et les faiblesses des
différents pays européens ne sont pas
les mêmes
lorsque vous avez proposé et là le fait
de mettre ça ensemble par contre les
modèles
qu'on peut utiliser sont extrêmement
variables et variées je vous invite
peut-être que je ne sais pas quels sont
les modalités vous me le direz cette
étude que qui a été présentée au
Parlement européen sur cette
infrastructure publique du médicament si
vous ne l'avez pas encore à disposition
parce qu'il y a différentes façons de
faire il y aurait la mise en réseau de
ces de ce qui existe déjà
où il y aurait l'idée d'aller vers le
modèle agence spatiale européenne où on
monte d'un cran ou de deux grands dans
l'ambition et il a toute une série entre
ces deux si on veut dire extrêmes il y a
différentes options moi je suis pour une
action européenne mais qui doit
évidemment être impulsé et soutenu par
les États membres en fonction de ce que
eux ils ont identifié et de leurs
capacités parce que forcément les
capacités que peut avoir un état comme
la France ne vont pas être les mêmes
dans un autre pays et donc cette
dimension là je pense qu'elle est
extrêmement importante et d'ailleurs je
pense qu'un pôle public ne peut pas
exister au niveau européen ne peut pas
exister au niveau européen si on ne part
pas des des réalités nationales
on ne peut pas développer un pôle public
européen de nulle part du vide
et juste dire voilà on commence de nulle
part maintenant il y a une comme
d'ailleurs ça a été le cas avec l'agence
spatiale je veux dire il y a des
capacités des compétences des
infrastructures nationales si on ne
parle pas de ça ça resterait
comment dire une belle idée mais une
belle idée vague abstraite
et l'autre sujet qui revient souvent sur
l'origine des pénuries donc qui est
multifactorielle c'est donc la question
de la souveraineté et donc
française et européenne voilà c'est
c'est le sujet est là et et dans nos
différentes rencontres on a bien vu que
c'était sur la
chaîne de valeur de fabrication du
médicament depuis les matières premières
jusque aux conditionnement primaires ou
secondaire du reste
la question c'est celle de la chimie et
que la chimie a quitté le territoire
européen et donc votre point de vue par
rapport à ce sujet là parce que en
France évidemment mais dans d'autres
pays européens les contrats
environnementales sont très fortes sont
des industries évidemment qu'on n'aime
pas avoir dans le voisinage de là où on
habite et donc est-ce que vous pensez
que en priorité sur le plan du
développement économique en matière de
de souveraineté SAN c'est une dimension
qu'il faut développer et comment comment
ça pourrait se faire
oui vous avez vous avez raison c'est un
débat d'ailleurs qui est plus général
vous savez qu'il y a un débat d'ailleurs
entre autres impulsé par la France au
niveau européen sur la souveraineté
l'autonomie stratégique
et c'est une question qui est compliquée
donc la commission pour l'instant dans
une série de secteurs comme par exemple
les semis conducteur
et aussi sur la technologie verte
stimule beaucoup
la question de ce qu'on appelle le Fast
permeting en anglais donc c'est en gros
d'avoir des permis des autorisations
plus rapides pour l'installation de
certaines de certaines unités de
production vous savez que c'est pour ça
que je parle de semi-conducteur pourquoi
parce que les semi-conducteurs au niveau
de leur chaîne de de production pose
aussi des questions chimiques donc c'est
c'est pas évident
est-ce que il faudrait reproduire ou ce
qu'il faut produire en Europe certaines
de ces de ces substances je pense que
oui ça c'est pour la première la
première question de la réponse
ou la première la première réponse
la deuxième
c'est effectivement il y a des questions
environnementales
or nous avons en Europe quand même aussi
là je suis plus
sceptique et douteux par rapport à
l'approche des garantir des permis plus
rapides je pense pas que ça a été ce qui
a poussé les entreprises à délocaliser
ça a été un facteur mais il y a eu
différents facteurs
et le problème est un peu qu'on est à
chaque fois dans le même débat où on se
trouve quand on veut une hausse de
salaire pour les salariés on dit écoutez
sinon délocalise parce que c'est moins
cher le salarié me coûte moins en dans
un autre pays européen ou carrément à
l'extérieur de l'Union européenne au
niveau de la fiscalité le même débat se
pose c'est ce qu'on veut une fiscalité
qui permettent de
d'avoir une un impôt sur la société
équitable oui ou non il y a aussi la
réponse des entreprises à lui mais si
vous faites ça on risque de quitter le
territoire alors je pense qu'un certain
moment il faut qu'on impose une
production européenne et est-ce qu'on
peut le faire je pense qu'on peut le
faire de manière différente ah les
marchés publics ne les sous-estimons pas
au niveau européen c'est 14 à 19% du PIB
il y a aucune raison de ne pas
attribuer à ces marchés publics des
conditions de production locale c'est
vraiment un outil à disposition des
états pour imposer et d'ailleurs des
directives européennes le permettent
permettent une série de conditions
environnementales sociales mais je veux
dire il y a je pense qu'il faut pas se
sous-estimer le pouvoir du marché
européen c'est pas c'est pas rien donc
il y a ça il y a la question
il y a d'autres moyens par exemple les
États-Unis parfois ils sont beaucoup
plus
radicaux si on veut dans certaines
politiques que nous ils peuvent ils font
des ordres en prioritaires auxquels ils
attribuent ils disent voilà vous allez
maintenant produire ceci ils l'ont fait
pendant la période vaccin covid donc ils
ont dit voilà vous entreprises chimiques
vous allez maintenant produire cela
parce que pour notre vaccin américain on
aura besoin de ça de manière assez
dirigiste finalement
ils ont une une loi de ce qu'il appelle
production pour pour la défense qui leur
permet de qui permet à l'état américain
pardon de directement intervenir à dire
voilà nous voulons que ça ça soit
produit et ici sur le territoire
américain pour notre sécurité nationale
sauf qu'il y a une dimension vous l'avez
vous l'avez relevé tout à l'heure de
sécurité nationale dans la santé
publique forcément si on l'a vu au
niveau de l'économie on a on a vu au
niveau évidemment des gens
[Musique]
vous l'aurez compris je suis moins
convaincu que l'idée de rentrer alors
dans la rhétorique de dire pour avoir
pour les attirer sur notre territoire il
faut baisser les salaires baisser une
norme environnementale et octroyer que
des
avantages fiscaux parce que là on rentre
dans une logique qui n'offre pas des
garanties
si ensuite les États-Unis qui ont une
puissance financière plus forte que
celle de l'Europe dise oui mais si vous
venez chez nous on vous offre un
avantage fiscal plus grand une règle en
moins et un salaire encore plus bas mais
du coup on a de nouveaux perdu et donc
on doit oser on a beaucoup utilisé la
carotte je trouve que le moment est venu
pour aussi dire la structurellement nous
avons des infrastructures nous avons des
marchés publics et nous allons aussi
imposer quelque chose nous osons imposer
une production locale et le moyen ultime
si on veut de l'imposer c'est quelque
part faire certaines de ces choses
publiquement encore une fois je fais
référence à un rapport à une étude qui a
été fait pour la commission
environnement et santé du Parlement
européen en mars de cette année sur
notamment les ingrédients
pharmaceutiques actifs
qui dit très clairement ben voilà il
faut envisager là aussi
des chaînes de production locale et si
on ne peut pas les garantir à travers
des incitations
garantissons-les à travers
potentiellement une production du
production publique ou des entreprises
qui sont très liées au territoire
donc je suis pour mais je ne rentrerai
pas dans le jeu de
limitons ou abaissons nos normes
environnementales
très bien c'est très clair
on a bien compris en même temps on
laisse le marché européen envahi par des
produits qui sont produits dans des
conditions
environnementales et sociales qui sont
pas tout à fait les règles du
fonctionnement européen donc le droit de
la concurrence et la commissaire le ou
la commissaire de la concurrence étant
très présent sur ces sujets là et à
chaque fois ne permettant pas de gagner
et de faire grandir le monde quelque
part aussi j'en peux le dire et bien
pour les médicaments c'est quand même un
sujet
et bien merci beaucoup voilà merci de ce
temps passé pour et de de cet échange je
sais pas si vous avez d'autres éléments
que vous voulez porter à notre
connaissance mais voilà c'était déjà
c'était très riche merci pour encore une
fois pour pour l'honneur et l'invitation
de pouvoir participer à votre travaux et
je vous souhaite tout le succès
et les Européens pour faire avancer les
choses au plan européen en tout cas
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à vous
bonne journée merci au revoir